I know something you don't know
oh yeah what's that
you are absolutely gonna be what's best
for her
writing and Publishing this book was a
long journey I actually came up with the
idea all the way back in 2003 I was
really interested in the Enron trial I'm
telling you Owen is not that guy I'm
starting to sound like most wives
suppose husbands have been accused of
white-collar crime I started to imagine
a woman who found herself between who
she thought her husband was and who the
world thought he was and in 2016 after I
gave birth to my first child I was able
to find the story I was hoping to tell
a little like you
which is about someone becoming a mother
and that's the book that we are turning
into this wonderful Series so where is
he Hannah where's my dad
he's gonna have an explanation you know
he will
the last thing he told me people will be
thrilled with if they're fans of the
book Laura Dave has thought through
every possible Choice she knows what she
wants to put on the screen my husband
Josh and I knew that we wanted to write
the show together and the beauty of a
television show is that you can be
expansive and spend more time with these
characters and up the propulsion of
what's happening to them like all
Laura's great fiction not only is there
a great Drive there's also this real
heart underneath it the best television
operates on multiple levels and I think
this does that I may not know why your
father did what he did but I know who he
is I love Laura Dave's writing it's not
very often that I feel I have to do
something I just have to do it I wrote
letters so everyone involved about why I
would really love the opportunity to
play Hannah Hall the letter brought
tears to my eyes she connected so
wholeheartedly to this character and we
really knew she was meant to play her
have you seen a teenage girl 16 blonde
pink streaks writing the book Hannah was
sort of amorphous in my mind now when I
reread the book it's Jen's face and it
will always be Jen's face she is Hannah
Hall to me but could you possibly say
right now that would make any sense I
don't know you lied to me
you lied to me too
even for people who have read it we are
trying to hone Laura's Incredible Book
into something Vivid and alive but also
surprising I read her book I was just
amazed how tight the story is we want
the show to be the same kind of thing
where you go I gotta see the next
episode everyone just really brought
their a game bringing the show together
in a way that it's beyond my wildest
dreams you said that people don't run
for no reason Hannah you need to get out
of there now
I felt that part of my life was over
[Music]